[Music]
[Applause]
welcome to this edition of bonehead of
the week we have some really big
boneheads of course
um two senators and a bought and paid
for supreme court justice uh samuelito
senator susan collins and senator josh
holly
yeah
holling josh hawley hauling ass holly
all in ass
booking it
speaking of booking it no
we'll get into that yeah we'll get into
that we'll get into that so let's start
with the alito uh part because i
actually have a video clip of the alito
yeah and where he's
where he's doing a thing that supreme
court justices probably shouldn't do
um gabe can you give the audience a
sense while i'm looking for this here of
what he actually did here
yeah so uh foreign nations were
critiquing our you know our basic uh
response to what has been happening and
he mocked them right so he
he
which is so which is so odd right as a
supreme court justice
you would not
outside of the opinion that you state in
your
uh your response to whatever the case
was you kind of shut the [ __ ] up after
that you really don't go out there
uh making more of it you just say this
is my job and this is what i do right
but he decided to go further
and and mock the foreign leaders who
were condemning the
the decision of roe v wade our friends
over midas touch put it uh eloquently as
always alito proving in front of the
world that the right-wing supreme court
justices are nothing more than a
political hacks unfit to serve on the
bench now here is the video where he's
mocking them let's let's listen to this
bonehead and then we'll move to the next
we got some boneheads to get to here
let's listen to this [ __ ] bonehead
over the last
few weeks since
i had the honor this term of
writing i think the only supreme court
decision in the history of that
institution
that has been lambasted by a whole
string of foreign leaders there there
might be a [ __ ] reason for that you
know here i want to point something out
why is he trying to grow a shitty ted
ted cruz i don't know weird it was like
you know every everyone during kova
thought hey i could
grow a beer you know what but this is a
really shitty ted cruz type beard it's
not even a good one right i don't know
i'm just saying the guy
the guy grows a beer like he makes
[ __ ] decisions on the supreme court
is all i'm saying
you're [ __ ] ridiculous okay let's
listen
who felt perfectly fine commenting on
american law
one of these was
oh for prime minister boris johnson
but he paid the price
[Applause]
no
no one no one in the us can speak about
foreign policy and laws and no one in
the no one abroad can comment well other
than him he can right he's fascist he's
a fascist he can do that right right
right he's a white dude he can do that
right and he's and he's not he's he's an
american and he he he holds the lifetime
seat of a supreme court justice so he's
allowed to do whatever the hell he wants
can you do me a favor and load in the
video i don't well yeah
yeah go ahead and load in the video uh
but let's let's listen
to what else this [ __ ] bonen has to
say and then we'll move to the next one
hoc ergo propter hawk right
but others are still
are still
in office president macron and uh prime
minister uh trudeau i believe are two
but what really wounded me what really
wounded me
was when the duke of sussex addressed
the
united nations and seemed to compare
the decision whose name may not be
spoken with the russian attack on
ukraine
jesus christ this [ __ ] guy so so this
is the just for context this is the same
[ __ ] guy who quoted what it was a
17th century a jurist who uh prosecuted
witches so the guy coming out here
trying to say uh let me go after the
people and mock the people that have
critiqued me taking away the rights of
women just a basic again health care
uh
right that we have right that women have
and he goes i didn't like the fact
because this is what he's really saying
he didn't like the fact that people made
fun of him he didn't like the fact that
he was the butt of the joke so he hired
some writers to write this little speech
that he gave and to make fun of those
people not very funny jokes because
those things are unrelated to
the the decision that was made it's like
whatever
but remember
this guy
used a 17th century
jurist to say
for a witch trial for [ __ ] witches
to say oh yeah women
should should not have the right uh to
decide what they can do with their own
body like what the [ __ ]
this is the guy that wants to come after
other people talking about him
well even in the decision and this just
doesn't affect us i mean they're paving
the way for contraception to be banned
for for for same-sex marriage to be
banned which brings me to my next
bonehead
susan oh they've learned their lesson
collins that
[ __ ] tony clutch
oh my god this this [ __ ] bonehead how
she's been on she's been on the list
several times she has been on several i
don't think she's actually won i might
have made her a dm one week about roe v
wade right well here she is um
speaking of same-sex marriage um you
know that that schumer and mansion have
come to an agreement on the inflation
reduction bill
which does a lot for climate actually
which is surprising that manchin has
reached that agreement with schumer now
rather mansion holds true on that
agreement we'll see
but susan collins is basically saying
that if you're gonna get the same sex
marriage bill
you can't have the inflation reduction
bill so you got to choose america you
got to choose you either want the
inflation reduction bill or you want to
get gay married this is really [ __ ]
like what what kind of ultimatum is this
where you're going to have no rights
they're not even they're not even two of
the same things
exactly but it's also like you're gonna
you're gonna put the rights of those who
have same-sex marriages up for [ __ ] at
stake and say look you guys can either
have this marriage thing that you want
or
we can deal with inflation like why
can't we have both why is it so why is
it so
like not even comprehensible to to say
like yeah as an american we would want
to fight inflation and bring that down
while also giving people the rights to
do whatever they want in whatever
relationship they want to get married to
whoever they want like
why why is it even a discussion of like
look you can only have one or the other
you gotta pick which one is it gonna be
tick tick tick tick tick like
they're [ __ ] ridic she's [ __ ]
ridiculous here
i mean absolutely she's saying you
either can have
the inflation reduction bill
or you can you can have your same-sex
marriage bill you can't have both she's
like you gotta choose and this goes back
to ted cruz fist bumping on the floor of
the [ __ ] senate because he's excited
that they killed a bill that he thinks
democrats want
yeah and it's not about democrats
wanting this bill it's about veterans
getting the [ __ ] health care they've
earned
jesus christ and democrats just want
that that's all they want is they just
want the ability for these veterans to
receive the health care they want just
like democrats don't want to tick back
and take away the right from people to
love who they want to love they don't
want to do that
you got this right why like right these
people were given this right it took a
long time for these things to happen
right you had rights for women that you
know in the last
50 years have had you have this one that
was what 2008 i want to say or 2000 i
forgot children no it doesn't 13 2013 is
when prop 8 was passed i believe so now
you're going to like for the last nine
years
it's not only the people the couples in
the relationship that are affected it's
those in that family anyone who was
adopted now you're like look
dad and dad mama mom whoever you are uh
were legally not viewed under the law
as your parents anymore
or as like
together
and now
you gotta live in separate houses like
it's a whole [ __ ] thing where it's
like insanity what are we doing why are
we doing this right i mean like
obviously i know why republicans are
doing this but the the the ultimatum is
like you can either have this or you can
have that like what does it mean you're
either going to deal with inflation but
have your relationship
or we're going to bring down and ease
inflation but you lost that relationship
that you've fought so hard to get and
you've had for less than a decade
it's craziness so there's why susan
collins made bonehead of the week along
with samuel alito
justice sammy lido here he doesn't have
the ted cruz beard right this is before
i have not before this is the first time
because supreme court justice you rarely
see them out in public the only time is
when they're like at a gala or at a
function like this but even then like
it's very rarely they're not they're not
talking about the way the only time you
get a photograph is when it's like the
group shot or individual shots that
you'd find on like the supreme court
justice website well i mean they like to
go and brett kavanaugh likes to go to
steak restaurants and well he he likes
his beer and he likes his ketchup on his
steaks right right it happens um someone
else who probably likes ketchup on steak
is the dishonorable mention of the week
representative marjorie hoof foot green
oh boy
oh my god what did she do why is she the
dishonorable mention you you you put
your decision this what what why did you
make her dm this week she's you know not
a nazi
this goes back to the this cause he's a
nazi
he's not a nazi she's a national
christian now see oh my god what a
[ __ ] boned this one is i we we talked
about this yesterday you know jessica
denson came in and kind of guessed
co-host yesterday yeah did a fantastic
yeah thank you to jessica yes shout out
to jessica denson again everyone go
follow jessica on twitter
at jessica
denson07 make sure to go give her some
love over on twitter but we talked about
the christian nationalism yesterday and
this this [ __ ] boneheaded [ __ ] where
they're they're embracing
they're embracing their fascism
just straight up embracing it if i can
find the clip here oh here it is here it
is this is on um michael knowles
uh do you know who this is some kind of
far right you know trader tv news
network podcast i don't know what the
hell this is i don't know what the hell
who the hell this guy is looks like uh
scott baio yeah right right young scott
baio honestly right like a young chachi
hey chechi right
i mean you know this is more tucker
carlson alex ty stein type [ __ ] yeah
yeah
no bow tie no ties yeah well casual
right cashmere sweater
casual rube a casual room not not an
official rube right but listen to how he
introduces her first thank you so much
for coming on
thank you for somebody coming on
he's really excited that she's coming on
his show gabe
this is so nice to have a nazi on my
show
but you notice how they're really smiles
here the and i think the reason why you
put this er on the dishonored mention is
this clip is this the clip yeah yeah
okay
and i think it's i think it's very
telling in our country that republicans
who self-proclaim themselves as proud
christian nationalists
have to be asked the very first question
when they go on a show is like are you a
nazi because that's that's literally
what he learns here a lot of people are
saying that you're a nazi just want to
just want to get it out there in the
open let's
let's just let's just address the
elephant in the room you do a good
impersonation of him let's watch
thanks for having me on michael so first
question twitter is forcing me to ask
this
i guess i guess elon musk who owns
twitter now apparently
not um is forcing him to ask this
question you hear this you hear do you
hear
the the the i'm being forced oh my god
freedom of speech is at risk here gabe
because he's being forced at jesus
christ let's listen
are you now or have you ever been
a nazi a national socialist he can't
even say nazi
nationals i'm not national
no i went through this yesterday he did
not he can't he can't utter the [ __ ]
syllables out of his mouth because
god forbid
he he may cause excitement for because i
would bet that he thought oh my god
maybe if i actually ask her if she's not
she's like you goddamn right i am i mean
no no you don't know but watch or have
you ever been
a nazi a national socialist that's the
national association
i don't know i don't know why he i don't
know why he fumbled on the nazis i don't
know if it was supposed to be one of
those where you're like oh you know yeah
like
josh hawley was running for i mean from
uh you know office or whatever like it
was when it was like one of those like
er slip i mean kind of moments or if he
thought like in his head he's like don't
say nazi don't say nazi nazi uh
nationals yeah you know right he's
trying to he was trying to get the word
socialist in there it seems right right
yeah to me yeah yeah it sounded like it
right you know
because that's what they like to do you
know they're like oh the democrats are
the ones who started the kkk like yeah
sure okay that's that's part of history
right but if you're going to ignore
everything since then okay that's yeah
yeah you're right then you're a [ __ ]
bonehead the same way as well they were
called socialists in nazi germany yeah
but if you go look at the history they
weren't they weren't what you're saying
is
a socialist that's not what it was but
okay
words friend but let's let's watch her
response to see if she claims she's a
nazi or not oh never i'm relieved to
hear that
yeah that apparently they can label you
things you're not and lie about you and
smearing her character on twitter and
they think that's perfectly okay
and this is what they have done to me
ever since i became a member of
my
congress
almost all those people on twitter they
they type out on twitter
that she's a nazi they need to stop you
know what needs to happen someone a
billionaire needs to buy twitter and
force people not to be able to type out
the things that they want to type out
and stifle speech that's what should
happen gabe that's what should have we
should that's what they want that's
right they won
they want free speech up until a certain
point right right
they want free speech you want to type
in nazi and then they're like whoa well
you can't say did you really want to say
nazi and you're like yes he's like well
too bad you can't say nazi right you
know he's like oh no you can't call me a
nazi you can call someone else or not
you just ain't right you nancy yeah
exactly like this margery taylor green
be like no never i was never that thing
you know it's like okay look she's like
they've been attacking me ever since
even before i was sitting in congress
like that's because you're a nazi you're
also the crazy woman who showed up when
you were not a representative you showed
up to aoc's office and started yelling
into her [ __ ] mailbox you're [ __ ]
crazy not only did she do that she
filmed it and then posted it on the
internet and then deleted it once i
think might have been patriot takes or
somebody found it and then deleted it
and was like no i never made the video
just like when patrick takes post of the
texts she's like they're taking my words
out of context it's like
we're reading the background
it's an image of yours you texting
they're taking my podcast out of context
you literally said these things you said
this july 4th shooting was oddly
suspicious of the conspiracy it's like
you said it you're the one saying on
your show no
nobody nobody edited they just cut the
thing that you said that's all well i
want to point out here because
she's on michael knowles show
and it almost looks like they have the
same background it's nice for a moment i
was like is she on the same set no no no
she's on her shoulder right yes she's
got her she has two at her show marger
taylor green and she's got the mtg logo
on the back she she has the she has the
mic again in the wrong she's knocking
position right exactly but she's also
she's also not in that weird ass hotel
room no echoey anymore
right this this mic
this mic is a dynamic mic which you have
to actually you have to talk directly
into it like this like if i was to but
mine is a condenser mic and that's the
kind of mic that she has at the hotel
thing whatever that is i don't know if
it's like a if it's like a back room of
a brother or what the hell she's yeah
but also that mic she has has different
settings so it's like a cardioid or
whatever right yeah i have different
words like i want to surround right i
want it just this part i want it on this
side you know if i'm doing like a
conversation between two people because
it's very similar to the mics we have
because right exactly you use a yeti
that's a yeti this is a yeti now this
one here is not a yeti this is a dynamic
mic it's like a radio mic you have to
talk directly into it which some some
people like those kind of microphones i
prefer a condenser microphone so i don't
have to eat the microphone i can stay
away and i'm really loud so i like to be
away from the microphone so you guys
don't have to
you know hear me too much but
but here she's again she's on this other
set which is weird
that it seems like she stole his
background i'm just saying it feels like
she copycatted him here i wouldn't be
the first time that she's copied other
people
and then try to take credit for it you
know or or or just try to rewrite the
story to be like i've always had this
thing you know right i've always
believed this thing you know i was
always a nazi i mean i was always a
national uh christian you know
a national christian a nat c let's
listen nancy a nazi
and i'm really tired of it i i am i'm i
it hurts me it hurts my family
it hurts my friends and it angers them
it also upsets uh people in my district
because they share the same faith faith
that i have i'm a christian
and they also love our country just like
i do so stop being a nazi
look look you know you know what i would
say hurt her family and her relationship
with her husband and all these things
even worse
than this
accusation that people are making about
her the fact that she had two affairs
that we know of
with a a trainer at the gym that she
worked at
and also a tantric sorry a polyamorous
tantric sex guru so i don't want marjory
taylor green coming here and saying
people are calling me these things and
that hurts my relationship and my family
and all these things i know i know keep
it together tony please don't please
don't throw up on the show you can't put
marjorie taylor green in the same
sentence
look all i'm saying is you know she did
some burpees and then you know she was
full adam so
marger taylor green cannot come out here
and make these things oh you know it
really makes me
me as a christian my christian faith if
you're really christian
you wouldn't have broken the goddamn ten
commandments
marjorie taylor green i'm a christian
and i love god and god told me to run
and man is the superior gender to me so
as a woman i actually shouldn't be
running because that's the logic she's
saying and another clip that we've
played before she's also saying right
now that's like oh as a christian i was
tested and i it hurt my family and the
things that people are saying to this
one it's free speech two you've got to
prove that it's not true marge and three
if you really were a christian then you
would actually practice the teachings of
christ and follow him to say oh yeah i
love thy neighbor
i will not i will not murder i will not
plant a pipe bomb i will not have an
affair
you know like what was that about a pipe
bomb what is that is that i don't know
i think it's 11 like like you know he
went up there and he was like
and also he had a he had a
tiny little slab that said thou shalt
not plant pipe off
oh speaking speaking of people who have
[ __ ] blow up in their face
matt gatz is also on bonehead alpha cuck
he got cucked big time dude holy this
was huge so tell the audience how matt
gatz
stepped in it and really got cucked here
all right so there is a there is a uh
a gen z activist her name is olivia
she's from texas she's from texas she is
fighting the good fight um she's kicking
ass down there and she's only 19. she's
only 19. so i just want to set the
context for what's about to happen
matt gates goes to his [ __ ] student
action summit in front of teenagers
makes a speech about how women are
are fat and ugly makes us you know yeah
we we
we actually covered the clip
that was that was over the weekend i
think yeah so that happened on monday
right exactly so
so that clip goes out there olivia was
like hey this is really [ __ ] up this
is fat phobic and this is uh
misogynistic like you're making this
speech this is terrible
he catches wind of that quote teats her
uh quote tweets her and then uh he said
i think dander file dander flight i
forgot what the thing he quoted
so dander raised dander raised right so
then it becomes is back and forth right
where she's like oh
now he's calling me out and then a bunch
of people from his side that saw that
post started to come after her right so
she started getting threats and she
she she's got [ __ ] tough skin man she
took that she took that [ __ ]
alpha cuck dumb ass
sex
trafficking
[Music]
man
and started to raise money off that to
say matt gates
as she said here well matt gates i have
to hand it to you i didn't think you
cared about us abortion right activist
but your spotlight and me has helped me
raise 50k for abortion rights in the
last 24 hours so i made a special thank
you card she makes a special thank you
card she gets it just the first 24 hours
i was just the first 24 hours she was
just getting started here dude the
[ __ ] engine was just revving up she
makes his thank you card she gives
people a template she's like tell matt
gates thank you for what he's done
that's within the first 24 hours and
this [ __ ]
it was like a it was like kerosene on a
[ __ ] bonfire this thing blew up like
a bomb in a in a capital city type thing
exactly within 48 hours i think they
were over 300 000
within 72 hours tony
gen z
the the group that she's with
they have raised the gen z for change
group have raised over one
million dollars wait wait with an m with
an
m with a capital m so here's her proof
for the first 24 hours this is at the
house because people were doubting her
people were saying she was lying right
like this isn't this is a real it's a
bunch of leftists and then she actually
got she actually got this hashtag
trending too
this is one hashtag she got trending
this is the first one
so she gets matt gates is a pro abortion
right so the updates keep coming in you
get 48 hours boom 24 hours let's hit
100k
within the next day
they've broken that and they had 115
thousand dollars that he raised because
of matt gates but now she's had a
million bucks but now she was on joy
read she was on all these other things
she's like talking about what's going on
yeah here she's lasting the message
right blasting the message
and getting it well over a million and i
think it's like
i want to say
close to 1.5 now well let's watch this
report from katie so you've called
gates's comments outright misogyny and
fat phobia we reached out to the
congressman's team about those body
shaming claims this is what we got back
from gates's spokesperson quote
congressman gates never mentioned the
adult's weight leftist media did what do
you think about that official response
from matt gates's office get him olivia
get him get him
i think it's quite telling that gates
office would try to keep the word
teenager out of the headlines so by the
time matt gates and teenager trended
together it didn't end so well for him
okay okay gabe gabe i i think i think i
follow olivia i've been following her
for a while and i think she follows me
and i think your mutuals do we need to
get her on the show next week yeah i'll
reach out to her after i'll reach out to
her after the show and see if she wants
to come on i i i am in love with her now
just oh
dude it's it is [ __ ] making its
rounds and the joke here's the thing
just like josh hawley running away like
that'll never run out for sure
because you know whatever asia's a
coward and matt gates the same way his
whole sex trafficking you know
allegations let's call what it is it's a
real thing uh
that [ __ ] with teenagers
that [ __ ] will never run out he will
always have that over his head and
olivia here [ __ ] dunked on him again
and again and every [ __ ] time along
the way she does an interview [ __ ]
dunk she gets she raises 300k 500k 800k
a million 1.5 she keeps [ __ ] dunking
on them where right now she's hanging
off the rim and just [ __ ] keep magnum
gonna break the backboard baby which
the other the other interview i saw with
her she's not just going to give it to
one organization she's going to try to
distribute to all 50 states
exactly and trying to make sure this
money gets in the in the best hands of
organizations in every state to make
sure that people who aren't receiving
abortion services are having trouble
receiving abortion services can receive
those services that save lives and and
help women get their actual health care
that they need so olivia if you can hear
me i love this
um what a beautiful beautiful cherry on
top
to make
matt gates
the alpha cuck cut the [ __ ] out of him
you did olivia oh my god for bonehead of
the week
she did a fantastic job fantastic job it
was amazing to have her on next week i
love her on next week um so i'm gonna
i'm gonna retweet this and uh give her
her credit for bonehead um and here's
the thing i don't see that stopping i
mean she could get to two oh hell 2.5
it's gonna
what could you because you know matt
matt gatz is gonna continue to be a pile
of [ __ ] right so yeah yeah if he's gonna
continue to be a pile of [ __ ] and she
can figure out a way to raise money off
that hell let's keep going right keep
going to raise money off this piece of
[ __ ] which brings me to
i mean i even said i said online i was
like turns out matt gates is actually
the best fundraiser for
abortion rights yeah you were sending me
you were sending me some stuff and i
i've been keeping an eye on this uh this
thing and of course monday we we railed
uh gates ourselves but the teenage the
teenager comment is uh
woo baby it was fantastic speaking
speaking of [ __ ] speaking of
[ __ ]
we have uh our bone end of the week our
winner uh senator
josh hall and ass i mean holly
josh holly look at him booking it just
[ __ ]
so i i think that's the reason why
everyone has him on the well there was
also
news news about what already it just
turns out yeah turns out the masculine
man that is josh hawley right that
[ __ ] pro
testosterone gonna [ __ ] do it as a
man
he's writing a book that's coming out
next may
yeah what's the title
uh hold on hold on i got i don't want to
i don't want to say it poorly here it's
called manhood if i had one maybe that's
what it is it's a
manhood
what is it uh yeah matt walsh what's a
woman josh hawley what's a manhood what
is a manhood no but josh hawley
uh i had it i have it here i have it
here um
manhood the masculine virtues americans
need
not a joke this isn't like being ironic
this is not tongue-in-cheek this is him
the same man that i think it was last
year or so or a couple years ago was
saying that uh masculinity manhood is
under attack and he is victim number one
of course he is well he's a white man
here's what i said about the book i said
josh hawley writing a book called
manhood is like steve bannon writing a
book on hygiene what the actual [ __ ] who
would buy who would who would who would
buy a book from steve bannon
on hygiene
let's buy a book from josh hawley
on manhood are you [ __ ] kidding me
what this is like the guy and this is
all after the fact of like he he the
[ __ ] generous here's it i just want
to point out the january 6 committee did
not did [ __ ] not have to do that
to josh hawley right they didn't have to
show that clip yeah they could have just
they could have just they could have
just talked about it right they didn't
have to they didn't here they didn't
even have to bring it up they could have
just jumped over like we're gonna play
the outtakes of trump and we'll call it
a day right
they [ __ ] went after josh hawley
because hard hard that guy and they got
him [ __ ] good because what ended up
happening is they bring up the fact that
oh yeah josh hawley was out there he's
like doing his [ __ ] pro insurrection
his fist bumped all the pro trumpers and
as soon as they were like hey you guys
got to get out of the building because
these [ __ ] got in and they're coming
they're [ __ ] they see red and they're
coming for blood and like oh [ __ ] and he
[ __ ] guns it down the hallway they're
like what did what did what did trump
call pence what did he call him i forget
what was the a [ __ ] yeah that's a [ __ ]
yeah yeah i just i just want to bring
that piece of evidence just [ __ ] guns
it guns it down the hallway and they're
like look if you missed how fast this
person ran by let's put it in slo-mo
like just [ __ ] slow mo catch you to
be like this is josh hawley the same guy
that was pro-insurrectionist outside
[ __ ] riled him up and said if i was
out there with you i would keep in mind
he's [ __ ] protected
protected by the blue
that were there
fighting for their lives to make sure
that the people that didn't get in and
when they did get in josh hall was
[ __ ] out of there he was gone he
[ __ ] got down the escalator he was
out of there okay who wants josh hawley
content here let's let's see what this
is
okay there's there's a little bit of
josh holy content for you let's see uh
what else do we have because i want to i
want to get to some video here of um uh
here's here's
where oh [ __ ] there's the there's the if
you want to play the forrest gump video
again you can
yeah well let's let's do that yeah let's
let's play that one um i don't know this
may or may not be something a piece of
evidence that the january 6 select
committee didn't have or something hey
you you look like an elite i'm coming
for you
run holy run
you wouldn't believe it if i told you
but i could run like i was escaping an
insurrection
and from january 6th on if i was going
somewhere
i was running
[Music]
that boy is hauling ass you ain't
joshing
he's booking it he's booking it now
i want to point out i want to point out
we played that video when you released
it yeah yeah and it actually got banned
in russia of all places weird weird like
not here very weird not here we had a
strike on our account not a strike but a
notice like a copyright notice we had a
copyright notice that somehow it was
banned in russia it was banned in russia
yeah
there's a connection between hawley and
russia but you know i don't know uh let
me see if i can find
i'm trying to find the um
ah damn
where is it
i want the damn um the benny hill
version
all right you play that give me a second
my computer's about to die i don't know
why hold on are you are you gonna are
you gonna lose out
i got two percent of my battery hold on
oh man hold on i gotta pause it but you
keep you find the video you just won't
see me for a moment okay go ahead good
we're gonna we're gonna i'm gonna find
the benny hill version here
we lost we lost sanchez here for just a
minute he's got a plug in his computer
um
down in the bunker not only is wi-fi
um very um
very scarce but also power apparently
um
here we go there we go
did you get it back oh yeah i got it
back i had to reconfigure some soros
cables over here
i'm trying to find this um
i think this is it this is it right here
okay here we go let's watch this one
more time and then we'll give josh holly
is due
[Music]
oh it's fantastic it's because again the
generous committee did not have to play
the video they could have they could
have you know made a comment about if
they really wanted to but they did not
have to show the video they did not have
to show the video in [ __ ] slow-mo but
they did
because you know what
josh hawley can go [ __ ] himself so yeah
him he's writing a book called manhood
right the
the uh the masculine virtues americans
need which is
hilariously ironic
uh not intentional
but as i joked about like eddie you know
with each book you'll get a free pair of
running shoes you know
um
josh holly bonehead of the week you
voted and it was overwhelming yeah there
was no question josh holly was the
bonehead so let's give each on each one
youtube and twitter he blasted through
let's give him his dude
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
and there you have it joshua own end of
the week everybody know what was faster
him on that in that race or him running
down the hallway in the january 6 video
who knows it was a hell of a race it was
a hell race and if you want to vote on
bone of the week go to tony michael's
pod follow us there you can vote every
single week for bone end of the week
where you decide who the bone end of the
week is and we break it down for you
every single friday make sure to
subscribe to the youtube channel as well
because you do not want to miss an
episode of bonehead of the week
stick around we will have some news
right after
the music
[Music]
[Applause]